Tjuta to new is an artist and a carver
his controversial work explores
everything from religion to social
issues if duty to knew were from
southern Canada he could expect the
media attention and accolades from the
art world that other artists do for
breaking barriers and holding a mirror
up to society but duty to new isn't from
the south he's Anouk and he lives in the
small northern community of Cape Dorset
Nunavut that means that much of the art
world that buys and collects so-called
Inuit art often bypasses Tjuta to news
work preferring traditional images like
igloos and dog sleds over Tunes of the
new social and environmental realities
of the north
art produced by the Inuit in Canada's
far north has been a hot commodity in
the art world from the time Europeans
first arrived in the Arctic and began
bringing inuit carvings back home in
what carvings remain wildly popular to
this day collectors just can't seem to
get enough of the harsh landscape and
exotic wildlife depicted in the works in
the 1950s Canadian artist James Houston
traveled to cape dorset to teach the
inuit printmaking he founded King yet
Studios starting in 1959 the prints made
in Cape Dorset were issued in an annual
collection the images of Arctic nature
and day-to-day Inuit life were an
instant success
collectors in Canada the United States
and Europe still line up for the
limited-edition prints on the day
they're released but reality in the
North is changing and so is its art a
new generation of Inuit artists is more
interested in depicting environmental
and social change in the Arctic than
they are in portraying the nature and
igloo scenes of the grandparents
generation there's only one problem with
this new work the art world is largely
ignoring it and nowhere is the art
community more frustrated than in Cape
Dorset itself the unofficial capital of
Arctic art ninguna khou-tv is a cape
dorset artist her work depicting Inuit
legends and Arctic wildlife often sells
out at galleries across Canada but she
makes no excuses for increasingly
exploring climate change and social
issues in her work even if they don't
sell as well I've never really lived
traditional a new life a different time
when my mum my mother was born they
lived out on the camp I live we live in
a community this is where I grew up
music like the Beatles
different generation sometimes I have a
strong feeling said no smoking in secret
bottles around her pollution that's what
that's what I see even though when we go
up holding you see garbage floating it's
not very nice it's not only our earth
being polluted it's our society
drugs alcohol you know a small community
it's a problem that's a problem that
needs to be addressed
TV hopes our art will show others how
climate change is altering life for her
and others in the north it's affected
the community I know it did when two
young men lost their lives because where
there used to be ice they lost their
lives going through the ice
that's when very clear thing for sure a
while back I did a drawing of a polar
bear with a coca-cola ten floating
because when I was in other one with my
son I stopped coca coca-cola bear you
know save the polar bear back we see
coca-cola cans floating him from him so
something I think Jared the irony kanojo
waka shauvik is also from Cape Dorset
she's one of Canada's most acclaimed
artists her 1960 work in chanted owl
sold for over fifty eight thousand
dollars in 2001 it set a record for
Canadian print sold at auction and while
Asha back prefers to stick to the
imagery that's made her famous she
applied other northern artists for their
new direction do people talk they walk
from one TV in eternity
no no turn it around up the bar oh boy
what is that what dr. Vischer why we
need it doctor not to matter take course
another to hold it don't move on it did
you burn it or not tell me governme but
while the arts community in the Arctic
may be embracing this new generation of
artists buyers and collectors in the
South have been slower to accept them
bill Richie as the manager of cape
dorset skinny aid studios the people in
the South still think you know it live
in igloos they run around dog teams I
don't have a problem here getting
artists to work with contemporary issues
they're their realities here are their
realities and I just encourage them to
do what they know I think it's going to
be curators it's going to be intelligent
retailers that are going to reach out
and find people that once loved intimate
art for its newness and its rawness to
have a new look to see the new raw and
the new thought that's coming out of the
Arctic Kerry Merritt is cape dorset
smear he also helps manage the West
Baffin Eskimo cooperative that operates
can unite studios
he says visual arts is a vital part of
cape dorset's economy and that getting
new artists and imagery to the market
will keep the community thriving there
is an increased interest in some of the
more modern the more in the modern art
and it's been growing actually the last
couple of years so we're still gonna
keep foot we're going to continue to
keep supporting that new you know the
newer ideas ken Yates studios will leave
town I think we'd be in serious trouble
we see that the future looks bright for
it we're just going to continue to try
to evolve it keep focusing on the core
stuff that everybody's been familiar
with but we like to try to come up with
some new some new mediums and new ideas
but in the meantime artists do tie to
new says he'll just keep doing what he's
doing I don't really care about
all right bingo
whatever be within couple near I don't I
don't care like I've always been free to
express how I felt at the moment
lots of times I'd it's just something
I've observed in the community who are
in the world and I just put it on
whatever working we put it on paper and
just I guess just put it up there just
just so that it's showing
I'm not hidden it's almost done I think
well I never really finished it's done
let's enlist more 10
my future doesn't look like much it
works